the ufc because i fought it and it was
like i have great memories in the fc but
yeah when i entered that like arena and
i see hear the crowd and i see the cage
i i those smells it triggers me to
horrible anxiety what do you mean i
can't even touch down in vegas without
being triggered what does it smell like
can you describe the smell it's it
smells like uh fear it smells like fear
is it like just like you know what
gladiator when that guy's uh
just watch that movie i just watched
gladiators that's what it feels like
like russell cro yeah yeah it's it's
really really intense so for me it's
really really intense is it the same way
you get before stand up how you get
adrenaline rush no for stand up i'm
super excited i can't wait you're not
nervous at all i'm nervous but i'm more
excited because i can control the
narrative so fighting i can't control
so fighting is a lot more scary or like
you're like oh i might die i'm close
yeah i'm close
no my question is how do you deal with
that how do you calm yourself down to
get focused like you just trust in the
process like all the training camp
you've been in you know this is about to
say
now this is where it is similar because
what he's saying is like you can't
control it but you you get confident in
your skills because you've practiced so
hard i know it's the best version of
myself that enters that outcome and i
put that trust in it stand up stand up
you have to practice practice practice
do it do it so you're confident when you
get into the situation so like like when
i shot my 30 minute special in dallas
right
i wasn't like i think my team because my
team shot it right we sold it my team
was like man i thought you'd be more
nervous like why like i've been this has
been three years in the making man i
know exactly what to hit i know exactly
what to do i can control the narrative
when i shot my showtime special it's not
like i knew i wasn't ready so i was so
nervous because you know like you know
when you shoot specials or if you're
doing a tv or something you know if
you're ready for it or not so you knew
backstage you're like oh no
for showtime yeah yes you felt these
feelings yeah
brian had to give me like this long talk
which is rare for me
were you shaking back like were you no
not shaking jesus christ dude it's just
a calmness
shaken
travis brown i know steve acts like it
was like you know in uh saving private
ryan like right before those things went
down
yeah like we're storming normandy
yeah it's the same thing here we go
i don't know though man i mean that's
must be nerve-wracking man to especially
like to walk to the octagon i always
like try to put myself in their shoes no
no that must be scary no the walks
once you hit the crown the music plays
there's no turning back and it's just
like here we go oh my god the worst is
waiting in the in the behind the [ __ ]
drapes and you and you're sitting there
you hear the crowd like what the [ __ ] am
i doing and then his team's behind oh no
god yeah all right here we go you know
it's so intense dude what about the ride
what's the most exciting part
when they announce your name and
introducing in this corner you know like
do you get excited when you do the face
off and all that
yeah it's very rare i get excited it was
your walk out song yeah yeah uh eminem
square dance oh
people
so do when you hold on one last question
so when you're out there do you just
black out no
or
or do you
or do you do you just wakes up in the
hospital
after usc just wakes up
do you have a game plan you're like okay
i'm gonna jab there's a game plan i'm
going to go circle
do a double leg there's a whole lot to
the face okay but what at what point
though in the game plan
like have you been in a fight where you
were like oh this game plan ain't going
to work yeah
like what's going on after every time
oh he's too big for this [ __ ] man no one
thought this through yeah you're like if
you get hit with a big shot does it like
rattle you and you see stars and you're
like oh no it doesn't hurt it's just
like uh it's like i'm gonna get you more
it's like a ringing no there's a real
ringing yeah and then a sense of like oh
[ __ ] so it's like yeah
none of it hurts inside there it's when
you walk out it [ __ ] hurts oh my god
cause you're drilling so high like
you'll just hear a ring you're like i
got clip
god dude
it's weird it props to you man you did
it when you look back and fight yeah you
ever look back at your fights and then
look at it and be like what was i doing
oh dude
well i got my son one to see him so i
was showing him uh fights i went on
fight pass and looked at all my fights
and i was like how do we know that dude
what the [ __ ] is he doing
what are you doing but then it triggers
like my old sets like that yeah
then it triggers memories of like that
week and what happened and like that
training camp and it's crazy man that's
insane yeah it's so strange what a ride
i blame uh brian cowan for losing a ton
of money on you during the andre
arlovsky fight he wouldn't engage but
yeah he just had you so hyped up that
that that camp
i believe bryant but now now i know uh
brian knights everything
[Laughter]
it was a bummer well because we're
training partners so when you know each
other there's like this weird
it's terrible when train partners fight
because i knew what he was good at he
knew what i was good at so we really do
that so you get this weird awkward dance
and then we're we're friends
so then like i could tell like when i
was against hold him against the cage i
like he was like yeah let's rest here
and then when he held me i was like yeah
let's chill here you guys i was
they're not
did you tell him slow dancing
come on man what you're doing
what the [ __ ] no this is telepathy you
know but i i definitely beat him and
then after he in the locker room came to
me was like i'll give you my half my
payment you know what i didn't what he
said
you know what we need to do is what we
need to do is we need to do a fight
companion but watching his fights that'd
be cool and then just talk about your
fights and what was happening that'd be
fun that'd be fun
would it really be fun for you yeah yeah
it'd be fun it was i got some story
like the brazilians big knives i thought
we should do that set that up
we'll do that for sure
i want to do that like when i was
getting ready to fight big nog and i was
like i was like sleeping
in brazil and i'm like man it smells
like like toxins in it well like it
smells like like there's fumes in here
so what they you know brazil it's like
fighting michael jordan chicago so what
brazil did is they backed up the trucks
into my green room what so all the fumes
went into my green room what so i was
like disqualification she's so sick
dude you're hearing this nick
chin yeah just qualification i'll write
a letter yeah that's cheating
that's [ __ ] up man and then at that
two uh i'll finish on this then we'll
wrap up my [ __ ] ufc store we love it
though so then before the fight you
fight no gear right and i was the
favorite i'm supposed to knock his old
ass out
so he's anonymous like really known for
this uh soccer league and soccer's huge
in brazil yeah the these two russian i'm
sorry these two brazilian gangsters set
when i was at dinner just sat down full
suit sat down don't speak any english
but my jutsu coach is fluent in
portuguese so he's talking and he's like
hey man just so you know these guys are
like brazilian mafia and they want you
they they have a jersey for you and when
you knock out noguera you put this
jersey on they're gonna give you 80 000
cash i'm like yeah say less dude [ __ ]
y'all do that he's like so they're gonna
come tonight before the fight then put
the 80 grand of cash in the
in the little locker that's in your
hotel room but only they know the code
so after you knock them out they're
going to call your room and give you the
code like [ __ ] yeah this is dope i lose
the fight i'm back in my room my [ __ ]
eyes out to here my whole family's
around me knock on the door
it's time to come get that money who the
[ __ ] is that yeah i was like i don't
know answer the door dad answer it's
those two [ __ ] just muscle mafia
mafiosos and they go we're so sorry and
take the cash oh my god and they go but
you can't keep the jersey oh great yeah
damn that's like a movie man
holy smokes i'll probably frame that
jersey yeah you gotta wear that to an
episode yeah i will officially to the
fight company
[Music]